precisely in Paris with a very special
guest on your script chenko yes we've
seen Amira before of course
international master former European
Women's Champion six times French
champion as well and living here in
France for many years you must be
nervous our mirror watching MV I'll come
so close you've known him for many years
as well since he was so hyper deep what
can you tell us about MDL and your
thoughts about this moment right now
well like today I think that it's not
easy to play in Paris because Maximas
parisian so everyone is supporting him
his family his friends and I think we've
been waiting for the French victory
since if I believe Yannick Noah victory
you know in the Roland Garros so it's
very important and of course it's never
easy with the change you know from the
rapid to blitz and it's rather chaotic
given from him so still he's in the lead
and I think he he can make it he had a
very up-and-down
day yesterday four wins four losses as
well today also is very similar and this
last loss just seemed awful yeah I have
to say that it's very unusual for Maksim
he he shows I think big stability
especially in blitz games he started
this tournament as the world number one
so probably probably something affected
him or you know he is not showing it but
he's very sensitive so maybe there is a
reason I know you are doing a
documentary on the magazine right now
following him from Abidjan and he saw
his very near miss in riga and now this
how are you documentarian side feeling
with all this drama going on so maybe
this is affecting him we got too close
but he's doing a great job and of course
after Riga you know we almost collapsed
because we wanted so much for him to win
and he deserves to win of course but
there are so many tournaments to qualify
for candidates so our documentary
we'll be finished after this tournament
and I hope that it will serve a purpose
to popularize chess and also to show the
other side of mixing now you're doing
commentary for us in st. Louis we're
gonna see you in just a few days as we
all go to the states you're gonna be
doing the commentary I believe in
Russian with our good friend yes we'll
be doing commentary with dare you can
emerge new champion Russian and I'm so
happy to be back in some place this is
for me
it sank to the chest sanctuary and it
reminds me of my like the days when I
was a kid and I was full in chest you
know on the television in Soviet Union
and then people were admiring
grandmasters and discussing the game so
this is really that much fear in some
ways it's incredible well we look
forward to seeing you there it should be
a lot of fun very talented lady emeritus
you can't go speaking commentary in
French Russia in English you name it
fabulous ambassador for the game of
chess
[Music]